If you're looking for a
unique deck that's
fun to play and the
average price of each
card in the deck is less
than $1, then
Kadina is just what
you need.  Kadina
is a Nago wizard with a
four-mana
Sultai 33 that
allows you
to play
morph cards for free.  And
when you do, you
can pull out the
card.  At the time of
this video recording,
aside from this
commander's print, the
last time we saw
morph cards
printed was over
eight years ago.  So
let's take a quick
look at what
morphs are and how we can
abuse them.
Now bear with me
as morphs are a bit
verbose and I
will explain it as
clearly and simply as possible and
hopefully
answer all your
questions.  And if you
already know how
morphs work,
stay because you
might learn
something new.  Morph is a
special ability
that is printed on
certain cards.  You
can play a
card face-
up for three
total mana
instead of
paying its
mana cost.  You can then
flip her
shirt inside out at any time
by paying the cost of
her morph.  Some
important things to
note.    A
morph creature is a
creature with two
faces without text,
a name, subtypes, or
mana cost.  This
means that
spells such as
Spell Trap
cannot counteract
this.  Cards like
Runic Halo
cannot protect you
from this creature, and
spells like
Luminous Rain
cannot be
used to your
advantage or disadvantage.
Additionally, morph is not an
activated
ability.  This is a
special action that
does not use the stack.
So, cards like
Piercing Needle can't
stop you
from morphing, and you
can morph to
get around cards in a
split second.  We
can also
touch on the
sister
ability of morphing
—manifest.  Some
cards will make the
player manifest.
This usually means
taking the top card
of your library and
putting it face
down onto the battlefield as a
two-
sided creature with no name,
text, subtypes, or
mana cost.
Its controller can then
flip it
face up at any
time by paying its
mana cost
face up,
but only if it's a
creature.  If it is a
morph card, the player
may pay its
morph cost.
And once that's
sorted out, the
next question is:
what's the game plan?
First, we want
to abuse
Kadina's ability, which allows
us
to use
morphs for free.  To do this, we
need to be
able to
use
creatures with instant
speed.  Then,
using the
card advantage
we get from
Kadina, we will either knock
our opponents
out of the game or simply
stun them with
our creatures' unblockable attacks.
Oh, do you know what
time it is?
Okay, then.
Morph time.  Dragonordon,
Triceratops,
Tiger,
Tyrannosaurus.
I'm going to go
over all the
best
morph cards for this
deck.  Don't forget
that the full
deck list is in the description
below.  To help
us deal with
creatures, we have
Affetto's Destroyer, 3-1,
which when
turned face
up gives another
creature minus 3 minus 3.
Next, we have
Curse of the Living, 43,
which allows us to
give all creatures
minus X-X, where X is
the amount of mana
we are pumping into this
morph.  After him,
we have Salamgar the Assassin
, a hard-to-block
morph that destroys a
creature with a power of three
or less.  Next comes
Skin-Thinner.  It's
just a blade of
doom on a creature.
For artifacts and
disenchantment,
we have
Anokh the Survivor and
Natuko the Avenger.  For defense
and counterspells,
we have Spell
Stealer Keru,
Mischievous Quinar,
both of which can
copy
counterspells and
copy other
key spells.
Cadence's silencer,
perfect
against Yaro's decks.
Misfire Weaver can give something
like Roof Tick,
while Wallbender
can redirect
spells away from you and
your permanents
.  Stratus Dancer,
Void Mage, Apprentice,
and Void Mage Prodigy
are more of a
counterspell on the
body.  For useful
morphs, we have cards
like Chrome
Shell Crab that
can be traded for
your opponent's best creature.  We
can
use both
Echo of the Trail and
Icefire to
bring back
pesky
opponent creatures, or
use them on
their own so we
can play them
again for added
value.  Sagu Mler
is just a heavy
beast to control, along with the
Death Misraptor,
which just
turns around when
something morphs.    The
Death Predator, Misrap,
is an excellent attacker and
blocker thanks to
his
Death Touch ability.  We
also use the
Gloomy Garus specialization to
draw cards, but
keep in mind that this is
not our only source
.  Additionally, we
use
Den Defender to
fish out any
cards from our
graveyard that might have
ended up there.  And our
final morph card
for this chapter is
Destiny's Gift.  This morph is a
great way
to protect one of
our creatures, as
it grants them
indestructibility, and as an
added bonus,
they also gain a
touch of death.  Now,
don't forget that
morphing is a special
action that doesn't
use the stack.
So, this ability
cannot be countered, and
neither player can
take any
actions between the time you
announce that you're
turning it
face up and
the time it
attaches to the
chosen creature.  Okay
, that covers all the
morph maps in this
section.  Now
let's look at
other
support creatures.  So, with
our helper
creatures, we want to
do a few things.
First, we want to
take full advantage of
Kadina's ability.
It's important to note that
the ability says
that the first spell of
your creature
you cast
each turn costs
three less, not the
first spell of
your creature
you cast
during your turn.
So we're going to
give our creatures a
shine and try to
play more
creatures each turn.
So not only do we
get to take advantage of
this discount, but we also
get this
great, great
selection of cards.  The main
ways we can
grant lightning to our creatures
are with
the help of Tfiri, Mage
Zapir, Viven,
Champion of the
Wild, Leeline
Premonition, and
Vidalkan Ari.  Leelaine
and Aari essentially
do the same thing, but
Tofuri grants your
creatures lightning damage and
also slows all of
your
opponent's spells to
sorcery speed
.  Viven not only
grants our creatures
lightning, but also
allows them
to remain on the defensive,
granting one of them
vigilance and
reach.  And it also
allows us to dig up
creatures.  Dalkon's AI is
the most expensive card on
this entire list,
but since it's
colorless, it can be
placed in almost
any deck, so
it's a very safe and
strong choice in
any case.  That's why
we included
Wild Rebirth
, a budget
version of Muse of the Sea,
so we could
cast another
round of spells
during one of
our opponent's turns, or
simply save mana
to potentially
pay the cost
of morphing.  Another
great
support card is
Exredon, a
five-mana illusion that
enters the game and
flips all
other non-
counter creatures face
down, turning
them into two creatures with no
abilities.
Extradon does a great
job with hex
roof, shroud, and
indestructible
creatures.  It also
allows us to
reactivate all of
our morphs.  Speaking
of reactivating
morphs, the command
saber allows
us to return a creature
to our hand while also
giving us an indestructible
creature, which is of course
great for
defense.  Crystal
Shard is a real
pain for enemy creatures
early in the game, as
they need to
make sure they
leave one mana
open for that
new creature
they just played
if they don't want it to
go back
into their hand.  Late in
the game, Crystal
Shard serves as a
good way
to drop morphs and
pseudo-protect
our creatures.  Both of
these cards
pair nicely with the
Sea Muse, but
then again, why
not?  To keep us with a
handful of cards to
play, we have an
extremely important
beast—the Whisperer.  "Secret
Plans" not only
protects our Morse
from Ellishnorn, but also
draws a card for us
when we turn the
creature face
up.  "Trace of
Mystery" brings
us land when we
play
face-up creatures and
helps us
go on the offensive
when we flip
creatures face-
up.  "
Unspeakable Thief" gives us a
cost reduction on
all of our morphs.
Pulling out cards and
constantly removing them,
which is fantastic.
For an even more
unique
card draw,
we have Primal Mist
, which is revealed as the
top card of
our library at
the end of our turn, and
then we can
exile any
permanent
under our
control and then
cast it.  So,
not only does the Primal Mist
generate a
creature for us that we
can then
trade for a real
creature, you can also
use the
Primal Mist as a
weird pseudo-defense.
If someone
tries to remove a
creature that
turns
face up, you
can simply
banish them.  And if
we have one of our
flash activators,
we can just
cast the spell
.  Then there is the Elemental
of Shepitlis.  This
five-mana 44 also
manifests as a card
at the end of our turn.  And
we can
sacrifice an
elemental
to Shepitlis, which gives
us non-token creatures
that are face-
up.  When this
creature dies, reveal the
top card of your
library.  So if
someone is going to
wrap the field, we
can just
sacrifice an
elemental
to Shepitlis and
manifest a bunch of new
creatures.  And the last
card in this cycle is
Thieves' Amalgam,
which will reveal the top
card of
our opponent's library at
the beginning of his
support.  And as an
added bonus,
if these creatures die
, the opponent loses two
lives, and we gain
two lives.  If you
can defend this
card for
one turn cycle, you will
most
likely win the
game.  Speaking of
winning, okay, so
we played our
morphs, manifested a bunch of
creatures.  What's next?  Well, we're
going to
turn them into a side
, but not before
we turn these two
twos into fearsome
threats that are hard to
block.  To
start, we have the Fang of
Sarif the Viper.
Not only does it protect our
creatures by giving them
hexes when they are not
deployed, but
when they are deployed
they are likely
to receive a
death touch,
which is of course difficult
to block.  And having
creatures attack
every turn is great for
us, as we have
Beastmasters:
Ascension, which can
quickly boost our
two twos to seven
sevens.  Our next
card is something a little
less suspicious.    The
Cunning Mage of the Path.  For
three mana, we get
a unit that can
deploy any
creature with power two
or less,
unblocked.  And while
this goes well
with our manifests
or morphs, it
goes really well with a
certain cloned
morph that we have
n't talked about yet.
Stay tuned for
updates.  And
finally, once we
reduce our opponent's total
life count
, we
can easily finish
him off with a simple
stunning run
.  Easy and simple.
Now, if you still
need a little
more to just
get over the line, there are two
really good combos
we can play
.  I've
only included one of the
two combinations in the deck list, but
you can easily
swap out a pair of cards
if you want and
add it.  The first
combination we have
includes Wooven, the
Shapeshifter, and
Brine, the Elemental.
Let's take a quick
look at both
cards.  Wooven, the
Werewolf of Form,
is a clone morph.  You
can either
use it as a
regular
cloning spell for five
mana, or use
it for three total
mana and
flip it
face up at
any time and
clone something
for only two mana.  The best thing
about this card is that
it allows us to
flip it back
face up and
drop our clone at the
beginning of our
care.  The second
part of this
combination is Brine,
Elemental.  Brian,
the Elemental, is a
six-mana 54 card with a
morph cost of
seven.  When it is
turned
face up,
each opponent
skips their
deployment step.  To
activate this
combo, we
simply need
both cards on the
battlefield with Brian,
Elemental face-up
, Visuven and
Shapeshifter
face-up, and
two available mana.  With
this configuration,
we can
skip the
opponent's deployment steps infinitely
.  We simply
flip
Weven's shapeshifter face
up, copy
Brian Elemental,
activate his
trigger ability,
and then
flip it
face up again on
our
support point.  The best
part of this combo
is that
thanks to the morph, our
opponents literally
can't see it.  The second
combo requires
Ruthless
Slasher, a
one-mana one-on-
one morph with a
deadly touch
that you can
turn face-
up by simply
revealing a black
card in your hand.  And when
you do, the
target player
loses two lives.
Combine this with a
free
sacrifice
like
Carrion Feeder or Sea of
Gaze and put Grave
Gardener
Yodora onto the battlefield, which
says that whenever
a creature that isn't a
token under your
control dies,
you may return
it to the battlefield
face up and
it becomes
woodland.  With these three
settings, you
can
sacrifice the
Ruthless
Slasher endlessly, turn
it around like a forest,
turn it inside out
, and
someone loses two
lives.  Just
repeat this cycle
until everyone is dead.
You can also
swap
sacrifices for a
team
war shaman and have the
ruthless
cleaver fight the
creature every time
it appears.  With
this extra
card, you can
kill any creature
on the battlefield.  Not
including the cost of
lands, this deck
costs just under
$100, but there are tons of
upgrades you
can add to the
deck.  To make
the deck more
cohesive, simply
add any of the
amazing
black card-tadtors
.  The nautical muse
goes great with
everything in the deck.  Oran
Frostfang is a
great card that
gives your
attacking creatures a
death touch and
allows you to draw a
card when they
deal damage to
a player.  You
can also include
key black-green
core cards
like Crater
Hoofed Behemoth and
Toxril the Vicious.  If
you want to see the
last cards that we
didn't cover in this
video, it's mostly
deployment and
removal.  Don't
forget to check out
the link below.
Now that you have
a few ideas, how about
watching
another video featuring the
Commander deck.
Thank you for watching.
Leave a like if
you enjoyed it, and
be sure
to vote in the
upcoming
poll for a
chance to have your
favorite commander
receive a
deck tech.  Thanks for
watching.  See you
next time.